the only thing we can be sure of about
the future is that it will be absolutely
fantastic
[Music]
well welcome everybody out there and uh
watching this live or perhaps watching
it recorded I am Brian Keating and I am
the associate director of the Arthur C
Clarke Center for human imagination at
the University of California San Diego
and today I'm also a physics professor
and today I'm delighted to be joined
with James Gates who is a professor at
Brown University he is the director he
is a brown theoretical physics Center
Director in Brown University which is my
alma mater where I got my PhD oh so many
years ago and remember with great
fondness and I only wish that he had
been there when I was there maybe I
would have had a different career and
maybe uh could have advanced to
experimental physics in my absence but
uh but today we're here to talk with
Professor Gates about his new book which
is called proving Einstein right and
some aspects of the continual Quest that
physicists such as I Einstein and all
the way up through the lectures on
gravitation by by Feynman and others
leading up to Jim and Stephen Hawking
have really been compelled to understand
what is the nature of gravity and how
enticing and how fascinating gravity is
and I wonder given all the contributions
you've made in physics especially in
supersymmetry which is you know in some
ways really sprang from your brain in
the 1970s while you were writing the
first degree on that PhD thesis on that
MIT and then had so much influence on
physics and in some sense even though
you're the father sometimes I joke
you're kind of denying paternity in some
sense you know that you're you're uh
maybe not as comfortable some of the
claims made about super symmetry so I
hope to get into all this uh we'll try
to keep it General so people will get
interested and get to know Jim's work if
they don't already know it already and
so first I want to welcome you back to
San Diego well thank you Brian this is
my first time on your campus I've been
here to San Diego before but never heard
CSD yeah let me correct you about one
thing I think important for anyone who
will be interested in proving Einstein
right to know I have a co-author yes she
is a novelist she has written novels for
30 years and she is extraordinary as a
writer so the thing that is kind of
weird about our book is what happens
when a theoretical physicist bumps into
a novelists because you know as a
theoretical physicist you know we're not
expected to be great writers and
novelists are not expected to know about
physics so the book really is something
that could only be done in a team and
we're quite proud of what we were able
to do yeah I was delighted to be asked
to see and and look at some of the early
you know first first edition of the book
over the summer last summer and was
really gripped by it as I said and And
discussing it with with Ewing with Kathy
or co-authors just wonderful writer and
so energetic about the physics topics
that are covered for a non-expert or is
it blown away but I said it reads like a
novel and I actually didn't know she was
a novelist when I said that and I said
it's truly a page Turner so
congratulations on that and I'm really
excited about that and I want to why
don't we just start right there so okay
so the title so proving Einstein right
so normally when I talk to people in the
Press especially after different events
that have transpired in my career I have
become reluctant when people ask me uh
what do you hope to discover with your
experiment the Simon's Observatory or
bicep or whatever what do you hope to
discover and you should I say well you
know jobs as experimentalist is really
to prove people wrong not to prove them
right and and maybe it's different in
theoretical physics but what is the
origin of that title what does it mean
to you and to Kathy well first of all uh
Kathy Pelletier and I uh respect uh
highly the work of people who actually
go out and look and talk to Nature
theorists don't actually do that to the
large degree we exist in this kind of
Duality between mathematics and reality
and we're always in tension uh trying to
find a human way to tell a story and so
Kathy and I and writing this book
um we're although we chose the title
proving Einstein right for the reader
who is actually carefully watching what
we're doing we also try to get the
reader to understand that science
doesn't prove things right it proves
things wrong and in fact one of the
things that I quote of Einstein which is
a real favorite of mine is uh I'm going
to paraphrase he basically says that the
life of a theorist is not to be envied
and the reason is because nature is a
very strict Taskmaster and she never
says you're right the most she will give
you is amazing maybe and even then
um
he conjectured that at some point maybe
all theories will be found to be wrong
so it's it's a very interesting relation
I know the public thinks that science is
about things being right but you can't
prove things right right yeah and and in
fact you know I think a friend of ours
mutual friend Alex philippenko at UC
Berkeley
said something to the effect that maybe
he's quoting in somebody else's name you
know and an experimentalist only needs
to be wrong once in his or her career to
have his her her career uh terminated
that a theorist only has to be right
once in his or her life to make a career
and you know Stakes are high and I think
you know Einstein had many you know
blunders and mistakes and and of course
our other mutual friend Mary Olivio
wrote a book about not only including
limited to Einstein but many other
famous physicists and and and and uh
biologists Etc that made you know
blunders quote unquote that sometimes
turned out to be you know prescient and
sometimes turned out to be not so and I
always find it interesting that you know
Einstein's predictions that lead up to
this book and the book spans over a
decade of time yes 1911 to 1922 and it's
a very loving portrait uh and you get
into the minds you get into the
psychology of these astronomers these
financiers these travel agents you know
it's just unbelievable how how were you
able to you know I mean you're
previously known for writing very
technical books and supersymmetry and
things like that or your other passions
how was it to both have to carry the
water so to speak for the for the
physics meat and potatoes but also to
get into the psychological and character
studies that you did sure but let me
first of all again Praise My co-author
it turns out although Kathy
predominantly has worked in fiction and
writing novels she has an amazing
ability as a detective or as a
researcher and so she was able to
actually for example contact the
sentence of the characters that we were
writing about and so we had access to
writings that the characters were
actually telling their families at the
time they were doing these things right
and even later so uh all praise the cat
yeah I remember getting an email from
her and I started interrupted she was
asking what's the maximum duration of an
eclipse and I'm like are you sure Jim's
not gonna ask that like uh you know it
was very it was very journalistic almost
that she was getting into it so and such
great things that's exactly right in
fact Kathy paid me a great uh compliment
recently we were being interviewed and
she said that I have in some sense
changed her as a writer and part of that
uh she you know her comment was as a
novelist she has absolute control when
she says a character has a blue shirt on
certain day the character has a blue
shirt on a date but she said she found
and working in this realm where uh
reality is fixed she found out that she
she had this deep passion for accuracy
and of course that's what journalists
want but that's also of course how we
make our living it is accuracy that we
deliver to the world because that
accuracy is what undergirds our
technology which allows us to provide
great apps to humanity and benefits when
you think about this great character
Einstein I mean no single physicist I
remember seeing a picture of Time
Magazine I think the week after he
passed away in the 55 or so he died in
1955 yeah remember when he died do you
remember that I don't okay and it's
interesting because my interest in
science had actually preceded his death
around 1953 or 54. I first got
interested in science but I don't
remember hearing about Einstein until
like 1957 so after he died so I was not
aware of his death I remember the covers
depicted you know planet Earth as seen
from space with a giant sign that said
Einstein lived here we all remember that
coverage he's so uh so much larger than
life as you know the beer the mustache
rather and the pipe and the violin and
the bicycle uh these things that that
um you know really fascinated him and
there are similarities I would say
between the two of you uh and that you
have many hobbies you have any interest
outside do you find that you know these
these different uh interests that you've
had throughout your career uh whether it
be or you know in their professional
level as a bowler essentially at MIT and
Caltech when you were post-doc or you
know the interest that you had in the
space program and actually trying to
qualify as an astronaut do these things
give you mere kind of psychological
respite from the the rigors of being a
theoretical physicist or do they feed a
different part of your spirit they feed
a different part of my spirit quite
frankly and the things that you you're
very kind in your praise and most of the
things you're talking about are deep in
my past they're not things that are
potentially going to return to the realm
of reality but I have all although I
have a deep passionate love for science
which started when I was four years old
I also understood about the personality
that I am that I wanted to do lots of
things in fact that for me the idea
would have been to create maybe 10
clones and that each one of them do a
different thing because I had that many
things I wanted to do so what I've been
able to do in my career is build
multiple careers on the basis of this
first one which is a deep passionate
love for physics and trying to get it
right at the mathematical physics
interface you don't want me in your lab
yeah because I will destroy equipment we
went in before and unfortunately it's
smoldering right now that's right so
I've always told people that that's
somehow something that's that is the
skill set that I do not possess and I
know that I learned that when I was a
student at MIT and so I have very great
admiration and appreciation for what it
is that people who go and observe nature
do in our discipline I often tell people
physics is not a faith-based
organization and the reason it's not is
because we are in conversation with
nature with our observations and with
our experiments and without that physics
becomes like a religion I want to come
back to that in a little bit and
hopefully I I won't forget but I do want
to touch upon the one last kind of
commonality and and difference between
you and many physicists that you do
share are in common and you mentioned it
during an informal talk you give so
kindly to my group earlier today and
that was uh the aspect of physics as
culture yes a physics should not be
divorced from culture thought as a
separate entity from culture and yet you
know most people would say there's no
way some stem geek or nerd that he or
she is part of like a culture that's art
that's you know paint that's that's
music what are you how do you feel about
about the inter you know the interface
between physics as a as a branch of
culture within ourselves sure well I as
I read well I read first of all I refer
to Albert Einstein as my hero Maximus he
is my maximum scientific hero in my life
and it is clear if you look at his life
that he understood that although he had
made these enormous contributions to our
understanding the structure of nature it
was within the context of a cultural
Matrix and he was pretty clear about
that
um and so if you for example one of the
quotes that of his which is a favorite
of mine is he says and I'm paraphrased
I'll never get it exactly right but it
essentially says that at their highest
levels Art and Science coalesce in
plasticity Aesthetics and form and so he
understands that physics as the kind of
physics that he was engaged in is in
fact an out a product of culture in the
same way that I and by the way do you
know what what he would have done if he
wasn't a physicist uh uh I think I had
known I know it wasn't you know Tour de
France competitor but no he said he'd be
a violinist and so he understood this to
me it's more than an ephemeral
connection as I've experienced
creativity in my my current life I've
concluded that there's only there's a
single source of creativity in human
consciousness and that this single
Source can
um be manifest in different ways whether
it be Arts whether it be science whether
it be mathematics but that this this
essential thing that allows us to be
creative it looks like it's pretty much
the saint from all the things that I
have read about and so it is not perhaps
surprising that when you look at our
greatest scientists they all seem to
have this message about science is
actually part of culture and one way by
the way that I think that that's true is
because of the way science is created
I like lots of music and among my
musical likes is classical music so you
know I like Debussy I like
rimsky-korsakov I like Greek you like
Lil Wayne I found out today yes well
that's a whole different access right
um but the point of bringing this up is
if you look at classical music and if
you're Aficionado of classical music
you can ask yourself well I like all
these things
why were the people who created them how
did they create these different forms
and part of that we know the answer to
it because often
um
parts of classical musics are drawn from
folk music which means that it's arising
from the cultural Matrix in which the
individuals themselves exist so if
that's going on with music I have a very
strong suspicion that it goes on
actually with all of stem that at the
boundary where we're trying to create
new knowledge it is that irrational
creativity the same thing that powers
the creation of music and art literature
it's that irrational irrationality the
illogical nature that drives how you
make Advance what Einstein made one
quote that puzzled me for decades which
was
imagination is more important than
knowledge right yeah I've always said I
don't want my surgeon to say that
yeah
exactly and so that puzzled me for
decades I first learned about Albert
Einstein when I was 16 years old that's
when I was first introduced with special
relativity I thought it was one of the
most amazing things that human mind
could recreate and then I came across a
statement imagination is more important
than knowledge and I was like how can
that possibly be because for me at that
age imagination was about Marvel comic
books superheroes it's about science
fiction uh it was about the imagination
uh just being a a space where I could
creatively uh engineer worlds within my
ears that's the way I thought about
imagination
but for him to then say that that is
more important than knowledge like
special relativity uh like Newton's law
which are things that oftenly uh provide
enormous benefit for our species how
could he say that was my question right
and so I a decades later I think I
concluded he was right and I think it
works like this knowledge is like a ball
a ball of finite size at any given point
in time we humans have a finite amount
of knowledge and if you go if you wait a
decade or so we have more so the
question is how does this ball grow and
the answer as far as I can tell and have
experience and watch other scientists
work is that we actually make up the new
answers and where does that come from it
comes from our imagination yeah and if
that's the case then I believe that one
can understand how the ill rational and
illogical parts of us that are embedded
in our cultural Matrix are contributing
to the achievement and growth of Science
and so interesting you mentioned that
because you know the center that I'm the
associate director of is called the
Arthur C Clarke Center for human
imagination and the title of this
podcast that we call that is the podcast
of the center is called into the
impossible and it's based on a quote by
Sir Arthur C Clarke which said the only
way to determine what's possible is to
go beyond into the impossible and that's
kind of this expanding sphere of
knowledge and and what is it expanding
into not the void but really into
ignorance or perhaps into the impossible
which we don't understand yeah I like to
think of it as expanding Into Darkness
because it's shedding light for the
human mind in such a way that we as a
species at least in principle have a
shot of living more Bountiful lives so
to me that's what the expansion is about
so getting back to the book uh proving
Einstein right that you wrote with uh
with Kathy pelletieri uh this this story
is really a human drama and it's it's
spanning continents and it's spanning
you know World War II and free oh sorry
World War One rather sorry I meant
pre-World War II uh World War one and
across the globe and it was a dangerous
time and it was a time of ideologies and
and passions and and stereotypes and
prejudices uh against this type of
physics I always think you know Einstein
had one thing going for him in this
quest to you know maybe prove his theory
of general relativity right which is
that he had the work of Newton that he
was standing on Whose shoulders he was
standing and they knew he knew that
there was something odd about Mercury
and that that's a little bit different
than than say the State of Affairs when
we find ourselves today as physicists we
we can make a theory uh but oftentimes
we can't I shouldn't say we I should say
you theorists and your in your fellow
theorists you guys can predict the
theory but you don't often have a
predict a retroduction against which to
compare in other words he had this
Advance the perihelion of mercury so
they knew something was deep simply
wrong with with Newtonian Theory alone
for hundreds of years perhaps absolutely
and so um how is it to work on this
expansion into the impossible as we were
thinking what would it have been like
for him you know as compared to someone
like you and and in in the modern era
where we don't really have testable you
know kind of retroductions against which
we can compare super symmetric
predictions well first of all we do
actually have some very mild
retroductions because you know in a
sense that you can't as a theorist you
can't write something that would be in
conflict with the standard model because
your friends would laugh at you
immediately right so in that sense we
like I say but the you're right the
retrodictions are less sharply defined
now than perhaps at any point in the
history of the field and that leaves
that leaves room for lots of people to
exercise their imagination and their
creativity to try to imagine the way the
world works I on the other hand although
uh you mentioned I was one of the early
adopters first adopters of the idea of
super symmetry I'm actually an
extraordinarily conservative physicist
and so although I will uh I think it's
valuable to explore an idea like
supersymmetry and I think I even know
why it's valuable which is not what most
my colleagues believe
um I think that we run a danger of
trying to uh trying to create scenarios
where there are almost no retroductions
that can find our imagination as I said
it's that conversation that stops us
from being a faith-based operation right
yeah so maybe let's get back to that so
um I've heard you and I have talked
actually about this notion of what
constitutes you know good physics and
and this is a matter of philosophy and
taste and but it comes down to
oftentimes comes down to Carl popper
who's a logician a theater a philosopher
who came up with this famous demarcation
kind of hypothesis which said you can
tell if something is scientific if it
can be falsified and uh in many cases
you know so Einstein's theory of general
relativity which is a large portion of
the subject of your book proving
Einstein right was known at least could
explain it although there are some
errors of factors of two in the in the
Mercury calculator that's a factor of
two between physicists uh and and it
could have easily been proven wrong and
in fact many people had deep suspicions
even that case and you mentioned this in
the book uh you guys point this there
were deep suspicions if it were correct
really even until after the 1922 or 1920
sorry 1919 solar eclipse so we're we're
celebrating the Centennial of the famous
Eclipse that sort of solidified
Einstein's reputation for all time but
but but even up until that time it
wasn't clear that um that there was any
room necessarily for falsifiability of
that and and I think people could say
well there could have been some other
theory that could have shamed the
advance of the perihelion of mercury
um and so you couldn't really prove it
wrong so is it the case
um that you see that Einstein was kind
of in a no-win situation like he
famously said well what if you're what
if the Expedition had been you know
proving you wrong and he said I would
have felt sorry for the good Lord
because the equations are correct yes I
don't believe that he was really that
confident do you
I do you do right I do because uh you
know we have to reflect a little bit on
his trajectory
so starting at 15
he in his mind begins to construct the
philosophical basis for special
relativity and with a very simple
question was the what would the universe
look like if I was riding on a beam of
light right so he starts from this
philosophical basis with his earliest
work and it turns out to be an enormous
Triumph it uh runs the table in the
language of uh some poker games right
and so given that he had had such
success and then the next problem comes
along uh how does he make his 1905
success consistent with the law of
gravity which is what Lisa's 1915 work
but as you mentioned he gets it wrong in
1911. I mean he just totally blows it in
1911.
um but when he finally gets to the right
answer
and is able to show the procession of
the healing of mercury comes from his
mathematics
um the thing that he also said there
were three tests that if any one of them
failed the theory failed one of them was
procession of uh Haley Mercury but he
knew that before right he just had to
get to it yeah
isn't a whole sort of the second one of
course being the deflection of Starlight
by
um by stars like the sun and the third
one which you well know because you are
an accomplished National Business the
third one was gravitational Doppler
which didn't get settled for decades
after his even after his death yeah and
so if you actually look at what happened
in terms of the history he says all
three have to be passed
one of them passes immediately one of
them provisionally gets a fast in 1919
and then in 1922 gets a more rousing
path and the third one doesn't get a
pass until the 60s or 70s and so what
happened well we've clearly did not
follow his standard right on proving him
right right and that's another reason
why we like to use that title because if
as you said in the book we actually
discuss that his statement of three
tests is not satisfied until over 20
years after his death yes right and so
that was the title is not to be taken
literally it's sort of a metaphorical
title that we want the reader to come
back to as they have read the text
because when most readers speak it they
say oh of course I know what that means
but after they've read the text we want
them to reflect do you really know what
he meant right and what does history say
about what happened exactly so getting
to the faith-based arguments that we
started to touch on a few minutes back
you know there's sort of a culture war
going on in in physics today and it
revolves around the question of the
reality of multiple universes and and
maybe you can say a little bit about the
the origin of such things within the
context of of string theory and
supersymmetry
um I'll just say in the context of the
experimental astrophysics realm that I
study uh the context supposes that if in
a period of exponential inflation
occurred at the earliest moments in the
universe perhaps a trillionth of a
trillionth of a trillionth after a
second after the big bang that the
Universe would unavoidably be
accompanied by a concomitant host of
many other universes and this this when
when it was discovered that there are
certain predictions of string theory
which in some sense could be interpreted
as also providing motivation for
multiverses which maybe you can expound
a little bit upon uh that uh that you
now have people speaking about their
belief in the Multiverse and uh you know
you've you've you've spoken about this
in the past but I wonder if you could
first recapitulate what what is the
motivation from just a purely physics
not a philosophy or theology for the
Multiverse sure
so many years ago I was um uh
participant in uh the television
production of the elegant Universe where
Stephen uh I'm sorry where Brian Greene
was the principal host but Stephen uh
Weinberg is in it and so is Shelley
glass shop and Shelley points out
something very interesting in that that
presentation
um and it's a problem in fact that the
dogs strengtheory to this day
essentially I'm going to change the
language of Shelley's or but essentially
what Shelley points out not with such
Fidelity is that the mathematics of
string theory
that has been broadly accepted by many
many theorists as this philosophical
hole in it and the philosophical hold is
if you take string theory in a simple
mathematical formulation it so it
describes the universe that has nine
spatial directions not R3 and so you
have to add this extra mathematical
widget in order to get from the nine
dimensions of the math or the three
dimensions of our observation this
widget is called compactifications
and when string theory was first studied
in the middle 80s people were pretty
sure there were some small number of
such mathematical widgets that you could
uh that you could use
um but what Shelley was sensitive to
although he didn't state in this terms
was that no one has actually figured out
how many widgets there are and as long
as you don't know how many widgets there
are to achieve this result that brings
the mathematics of string theory down to
be consistent with their with our um
with our observations of dimensionality
then you have no way to falsify it so he
Nails the point precisely and in a way
that most
people who are aficionados or string
theory have yet to address it took me a
decade to conclude that he was right
that it's the counting of the number of
the way I like to say it until you can
tell me mathematically how to count the
number of widgets you do not have a
theory that's falsifying
now on the other hand uh String Theory
does have incredibly large numbers of
these widgets depending on what variety
that you want to use is collabi outcome
factification and there's
non-geometric structures and this
asymmetrical orbital folds the list goes
on and on and one of the amazing thing
for me is that every year someone figs
out another one of these widgets yeah so
oh we found another widget here right
and so that that in and of itself is
saying that there's an incompleteness
and so until you satisfy that condition
you can't falsify it and that's what
that's really the essence of Shelley's
message
so I think it was right
on the other hand
um I about uh several months ago I
brought this issue up with a physicist
at Harvard uh Cameron baffa who is one
of the folks who are working on a part
of string theory there's a part of
strength they call F Theory and in that
there is
a fair body of mathematical evidence
that you can count the widgets
if you could extend that to all possible
string theories then Shelley's objection
goes away and it becomes falsifiable but
even vafa who's the proponent of
something called The Swamp land which
you've probably heard about in the
context of f Theory which is really the
the initial well one of the places he
spends a lot of his intellectual energy
even there there is no absolute proof of
the counting and so until that happens
I'm going to be highly
so before we wrap up I do want to think
you know years in the future hopefully
not uh decades and decades as it took
Einstein to get verified but if you
could imagine uh future physicists and
novelists collaborating together to
write a book called proving Gates right
um what would it be what would the
contributions be what would you most
like to see you know if you could have
one Divine being answer any one question
about the nature and origin of the
universe or the properties there of its
entities they're in what would it be
what fascinates you the most that you'd
most like to know the answer to
so as you know Brian
um I have been pursuing some
well some mathematical approaches that
have been described as avant-garde or
eclectic they involve taking
differential equations and then
recasting them in the language of
networks and then studying the
properties of these networks so we call
these networks of dinkris
and this is uh something that I've
received a fair amount of criticism like
what in the world why are you doing this
and the answer turns out to be because
there are problems in at the basis of
string theory that I am aware of from
when I was a postdoc at Harvard that no
one has ever solved and so that suggests
that if you have a problem where you
know my
the community to which I belong contains
many individuals of which I am in total
awe and admiration of their intellect
just absolutely the case and yet none of
these people have been able to solve
this particular problem I'm describing
that suggests that you need a new tool
to attack the problem and this network
approach was my effort to start to
develop a new kind of tool to attack
this problem so I've referred this
problem as a white whale in my life I'm
like Ahab chasing this white whale
through the darkness that the knowledge
expands into right and so if if
the good Lord would suddenly appear
before me said Jim I'll you know you're
going to die but in order to do that
I'll give you an answer
do you still want to ask the question I
would ask the question and the question
would be
how do I find the irreducible
representations of supersymmetry
very good well I want to finish this uh
at this interview with the question I
like to ask people and it involves a
general nature of imagination and
curiosity and I do that with all the
guests that I'm uh so privileged to
interview such as yourself and it really
involves you know this this you know
your first career in some sense going
back to 1972 as a student at MIT where
you began your career as an educator and
my question to you is and there's no
right or wrong answer as far as I can
tell is can you teach you know the kind
of creativity that physicists such as
yourself need to employ in their craft
or is it sort of a Divine gift that is
you know visited upon some people by
fortunes goodliness and Providence in
some sense uh or is it just random luck
let me respond by slightly changing your
question Brian
by changing to the issue of Genius
because
I no longer think about genius the way I
did when I was a young physicist because
I've been around very bright people and
I've watched what's happened
and
I don't I well first of all I don't
think you can teach it
but what you can do is to support
the idiosyncr idiosyncratic thinking
patterns that exist in every single
individual that's what makes us
different that you can add
an increased possibility or probability
that the indiosyncratic nature of an
individual's thinking will lead to a
unique Innovative answer that's what I
think you can do as a teacher very good
well uh Dr Jim Gates Ford Foundation
Professor thank you for this opportunity
to speak to you and your audience yes
thank you so much for being here with us
the only thing they can be sure of about
the future is that it will be absolutely
fantastic
[Music]